You know when a craving heads and you can't stop thinking about it?
That's what happened to me.
All I wanted was a focaccia sandwich,
so that's what I had to make.
Obviously also needed a lunch beverage.
I can't do the taste of water lately,
so I use liquid.
IV love how these come sugar free
and they have improved hydration in comparison to just water alone,
which postpartum I love.
After making my beverage,
I move on to making a quick Jimmy Cherry.
Chop up some parsley,
shallot, garlic.
Combine that with some olive oil,
red wine vinegar,
some oregano, salt,
some lemon.
Give that a good mix and set that aside while I chop up some tomatoes.
Wanted to keep these really simple,
so I just cut them in quarters,
drizzle them with some olive oil and balsamic glaze.
This point, my focaccia had risen,
so I dimpled it
and then decided to spread some red onions on top
and some of that chimichurri before popping it in the oven to bake.
Moved on to making some chicken cutlets.
So I season my bread crumbs and flour
before whisking up some eggs to dip my chicken in.
And then I did a three step process.
The flour first,
then the egg,
and then the bread crumbs before putting my chicken on a wire rack.
Repeated this step with all of my chicken,
and then fried it up in some olive oil and butter until it was golden.
Brown. Once that was done,
I set that aside and let it cool on a wire rack
and pulled my focaccia out the oven.
Sandwich needed some kind of creamy sauce,
so I made elabrian chili aioli to go alongside it.
And then it was time to assemble.
So I cut my bread in half,
spread some aioli on top the chicken,
some arugula, the tomato chimichurri.
Obviously needed to cut that in half.
And there you go.
This hit the spot and was so good.